cracking down on player vaccinations for
covet 19 just
days before training camps begin in a
memo to all 32 teams commissioner roger
goodell said
outbreaks among unvaccinated players
could cause teams to forfeit games
and those forfeits will cost big money
dana jacobson
reports here's brady's pass
at the end of the 2020 nfl season the
league managed to crown a champion
but getting there wasn't easy covet
outbreaks among teams
forced the league to reschedule several
games which caused logistical and
financial headaches
nfl team owners want to have these games
played in full and as safely
as possible jonathan jones is a cbs
sports nfl insider
he says the league hopes to avoid a
repeat of last year
which is why it sent a memo to all 32
teams thursday
warning that if a covet spike on a team
postpones a game which can't be
rescheduled
the team responsible will have to
forfeit shoulder the financial losses
and players on both teams won't get paid
the memo upset several league stars like
all pro wide receiver deandre
hopkins who posted then deleted this
tweet
being put in a position to hurt my team
because i don't want to partake in the
vaccine
is making me question my future in the
nfl
he later posted i got about nine more
years in me
you look at the monetary side of this
and of course it does not
benefit the owners to miss out on any of
these games
jones says the nfl memo is proof that
owners don't think enough players are
protected
you want to be able to deliver on the
entire 17 game schedule and then play
a full postseason and deliver the
product to
all of your fans all of your media
partners dr anthony fauci told cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell that the nfl
is sending a strong message when an
organization as big as the nfl
sends a message like that what do you
think that does
for other organizations and businesses
i think that gives them the impetus
to do the same sort of thing and i think
you're going to be
seeing that there will be local mandates
be they from colleges and universities
or places of business that there will be
pressures
for people to get vaccinated dana
jacobson
cbs news new york well something to note
according to the nfl network
only 14 of the 32 teams less than half
have at least 85 percent of its players
vaccinated